hey guys is Vadim and welcome to max
Tech when it comes to buying an iPad pro
you've got the choice between the 2017
10.5 inch iPad pro for 649 dollars or
the brand-new 2018 iPad pro for at least
seven hundred and ninety nine dollars
today we'll be comparing them to see
which iPad pro model is the right choice
for you starting with the design the
2018 iPad pro features a brand new
design with flat edges instead of the
old ipad pro's curved and chamfered
edges I personally love the new design
except that the flat edges do feel a
little bit weird in the hands until you
get used to it the home button is now
gone so the top and bottom bezels are
slimmed down making for nice even bezels
all around the curved edge display I
also love that the front of the new iPad
pro is now blacked out just looking at
them side by side it's easy to see that
the old iPad pro looks outdated compared
to the new iPad pro this alone might be
enough of a reason to buy the new one
instead with a home button now gone the
2018 pro gets face ID instead and let me
tell you it works great since you can
use it in practically any orientation
the displays themselves actually aren't
any different but they both look amazing
compared to smaller iPads they're both
super bright and support Apple's pro
motion technology which allows the
display to refresh at up to 120 times a
second making animations and navigation
buttery smooth unfortunately the new
iPad pro is the first one ever to get
rid of the headphone jack but Apple does
sell a $9 adapter so it's not too big of
a deal the new pro finally switches over
to USBC allowing you to connect USB see
accessories but you still can't connect
external storage drives to me the USB C
port is nice because you can easily
charge the new iPad pro using a USB C
macbook charger one huge benefit is that
the new pro comes with an 18 watt
charger instead of the old 12 watt
charger that came on basically every
ipad so it's gonna charge much quicker
with the new iPad pro comes a new Apple
pencil which charges wirelessly by
attaching it to the side of the iPad pro
this new method of charging is a
thousand times better than the old plug
into the Lightning port method this will
make sure your pencil is always topped
off in the magnetic connection is pretty
strong so it won't easily get lost the
new Apple pencil is $30 more expensive
than the old one but
think it's worth it since you wouldn't
want to buy the old pencil and then have
to buy the new one in the future anyway
the new pencil looks better and it also
gets a new DoubleTap feature that can
instantly switch between tools so to me
there's no comparison whichever one you
choose they both perform incredibly well
with very minimal lack compared to other
iPads that lack promotion technology now
let's compare performance starting with
Geekbench for cpu benchmark we got a 90
percent higher score on the new iPad pro
in the graphics test we only saw an
increase of around 36% but when we tried
and Tutu's graphics test we had a score
that was over twice as high as a 10.5
inch iPad pro now that's absolutely
insane considering how powerful the ten
point five inch pro already was we then
run base marks metal graphics test in
the 11 inch iPad pro again scored over
twice as high running GFX benches 1080p
Manhattan test the new 11 inch iPad pro
scored 133 percent higher than the 10.5
inch model substantially more than
double the score we decided to run a
more realistic test exporting and edited
one-minute 4k 60p video using Adobe rush
the 11 inch iPad pro finished exporting
in only 2 minutes and 56 seconds
compared to 6 minutes and 10 seconds on
the 10.5 inch iPad pro that's again more
than twice as fast
finally testing photo editing which
doesn't really use much of the graphics
chip we exported 50 edited JPEG images
in Adobe Lightroom cc the 11 inch iPad
pro finished in 2 minutes and 33 seconds
while the 10.5 inch iPad pro finished in
2 minutes and 58 seconds it's easy to
see just how much more powerful the new
11 inch iPad pro is at least four
graphics intensive tasks however to be
completely honest you probably won't
notice that big of a difference only
because the 10.5 inch iPad pro was
already able to handle most iOS apps
with ease to really see the new iPad pro
shine we're gonna have to wait for even
more power demanding apps and software
we decided to compare the cameras on
both ipad pro's and as you can see the
new Pro turns out much better looking
photos the quality has improved as well
as dynamic range now the biggest
difference is seen on the front end
thanks to face ID in the true depth
sensor the new iPad pro can out
portrait selfies which look many times
better than any selfie you can take on
the 10.5 inch iPad pro this also means
that you get features like an emoji and
momochi which I've come to realize don't
really matter much at all since I've
only used them once since I got my
iPhone 10's max months ago lastly let's
talk about bengay honestly I don't think
it's a big deal at all the old iPad pro
is definitely more durable but we've
experienced zero issues so far with the
new one overall there's absolutely no
comparison between the 10.5 inch iPad
pro and the 2018 iPad pro the new one is
so much better in almost every way
there's only one thing stopping me from
recommending the new iPad pro to
literally everyone looking to buy an
iPad pro and that's the price at $799
for the pro in $130 for the Apple pencil
it's simply unaffordable for a lot of
people so my conclusion is this if you
have the extra cash and you can buy
either one definitely by the 2018 iPad
pro instead of saving some cash on the
10.5 inch iPad pro you won't regret your
purchase
now if the new iPad pro looks appealing
but it's way out of your price range try
to find a used 10.5 inch iPad pro that
comes with an Apple pencil already if
you'd rather not
I'd recommend waiting until March when
Apple will probably release a new budget
iPad thanks for watching guys and make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on more max tech videos we'll see you in
the next one